to me that defines me as a great
entrepreneur somebody who's trying to
put other people on
in all his activities
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
gary how's it going well my friend how
are you
i am honestly incredible that makes me
happy
i am beyond amazing i'm on this uh
21 day deepak chopra abundance
meditation and it's
life-changing good for you you know
um should we dive in i would love that
yes done and done i want to welcome back
um gary vee
aka vaynerchuk back to the in my field
podcast
uh an incredible entrepreneur you know
new york times bestseller
author speaker internet personality
businessman
honest hustler music fan investor
you name it he he is he is that um
so how we usually start is uh thoughts
feelings
um emotions beliefs on the inside create
your outside exterior gary so
how are you feeling right now in this
moment
grateful you know i am
i'm feeling very grateful uh i'm feeling
optimistic
i'm feeling motivated
um patient
i'm feeling patient uh
i'm feeling curious curious comes to
mind
happy good good is there ever times when
when you're not those
and and if so how do you best deal with
them
yeah things pop in you know things pop
in i i you know as
now that i'm 45 and know a lot of people
intimately
i've come to realize a lot less often
than most people
you know i do think gratitude and
optimism
um accountability yes
you know tenacity i call it goat
thinking right
gratitude optimism accountability and
tenacity
lead to a very good framework yes the
remix version
yes um so when i get upset
or feel down you know here are the
things that happen
uh i'm like a very good fighter one
punch to the face
never one tough thing
in business my day-to-day never
loss of a big client um great person
quits um
an hr headache that i'm upset about
people not being nice to each other
uh a million things that happen when
you're an entrepreneur with 2000
employees
never six
beautiful shots in a row you know if you
think about
what buster douglas did to mike tyson in
that round those were
six clean shots in a row i go down
right and so
i um when that happens
or what's in a blue moon where i wake up
and i'm not in the best mood mainly
normally historically on just
probably fatigue even though on the
record because
you know i think i get labeled unfairly
around hustle porn
i i've been for ever talking about seven
eight nine hours of sleep i i get
i i fight for sleep more than anything
but i fight secondarily to be productive
while awake if you have big ambition
yes so that's the nuance nonetheless
um sometimes i wake up i always go to
the same place
gratitude and perspective yeah i
immediately go i'm sorry to i'm sorry
let me just get this context for you to
build on i go into yes i might not be in
the mood to work or
yes somebody might be sick or or
my child might be stressed or dad might
be upset
but damn it everyone's actually alive
and healthy and like
you know and so i very much go to that
end of all places of health and you know
happiness
health as happiness excuse me and so
that usually shakes me out of it
like i basically go into yeah but if
this wasn't going on
and i got a phone call at three o'clock
in the morning while i was sleeping last
night
that said xyz atrocious thing happened
would i be happier of course not and so
that it keeps
most things in very deep perspective
absolutely
it's um it's funny you talk about sleep
because that was actually my next
question i mean
i used to struggle with sleep um to a
point you know that it would be very
on and off and then it would affect my
day and this is the
i'd like to you know speak from a place
of the difference between
activity and action so you know action
is like i'm hungry
i'm gonna go get some food that's a
spontaneous action activity is
i'm not really hungry but i'm nibbling
at food you know like the activity of
of say washing dishes is the chore
or the action of washing dishes is
actually feeling the warm water
the bubbles hearing the water go down
the sinkhole the difference is you
become it rather than
just you know just are separate from it
and i think i think as i've started
operating like that my energy levels
have gone through the roof so even like
speaking with on a podcast is speaking
absolute truth
with full action not activity not just
you know
mumbling or speaking some things um and
since i've started doing that i mean i'm
in bed literally because you know i have
a 14 month old
i i go to bed at 8 8 p.m i do my 15
minute meditation i read
constantly there's no tv there's no
distraction no phones and
and i and i sleep and it's only by the
way
i would argue reading is far more of a
distraction than people
people put reading on a pedestal on tv
and phone on a negative
i don't think it's stimulation because
i'm sure you
agree with me as a reader you can get
plenty stimulated while reading
100 yes i i actually think it's
peace of mind yes well
there's actually no such thing as peace
of mind peace of no mind
fair enough because when you have mind
there's no peace
so for me whether it's that
context or juxtaposition whether it's
ambition balanced with complacency of
happiness and acceptance
i always sleep well
and have and the only times i don't is
when i'm anxious
it's not super complicated and i've had
a couple of major things in my life
through
the years that have made me anxious and
i don't sleep as well it's not super
complicated
and so um that makes a lot of sense to
me
and i think when you were just talking
and this has always been a big
thing for me i love my process
when you were talking being right the
water like that's the only thing i've
ever done
it's why i've been so
specific is the word i would use such a
bad student
when i'm not a dope but i could have
easily done it but i had so much
conviction
in the passion of my process that i was
willing to punt school
to work on my skill of observing people
and doing entrepreneurship whether that
was baseball cards
or reading sports card magazines or
reading
wine magazines when i got into wine i've
i've always been so into the process of
i enjoyed and continue to enjoy when i'm
underestimated
and not paid attention to far more
than the alternative i get great
pleasure
out of the early days of wine library
when nobody knew who i was
building building i'm a builder building
that business
i don't need the accolades i don't need
the attention i don't need the trophies
i don't need the money
i need my process and i think that's
what you're referring to
and when you're about the process versus
what what the process
gives you i think the relationship
changes dramatically
i think that's a different i mean me
because following you i i it's not about
the things that you do
it's how you do them for me because i'm
a study of people too so you know you're
reading a documentary and i know
you know everything around you i already
know that's your thought process because
it's the law of attraction you are the
magnet to that
um and then seeing you the way you do
things is you very much
lead with the heart and i understand
yeah we think with the head and all that
type of stuff
the head is in the past the heart is in
the now and the future and i
study you and i see that in every single
thing you do because you
lead with the heart
thank you because this goes back to
gratitude you know
you can't imagine what that feels like
for me just hearing that i think
humility you know
i think i'm i think i'm extremely
misunderstood by a lot of people
and it and i i i actually weirdly enjoy
it
not because i'm like evil to myself
because it educates me it it it's a it's
a thesis and what i believe which is
communication and context are everything
and so you know i think
um my energy my natural communication
energy
easily disguises a lot of things i'm up
to so when i hear
you say that you know i'm flattered by
because i think you have to do a little
bit you have to spend a few seconds on
it
because i'm not a very easy read yeah
right yes um and i don't know if that
was your experience what you first felt
yeah as actually this could be fun for
the audience do you recall the first
time
you came across me do you have a
recollection of
what your hot take was because because i
do think
i invoke very opposite reactions the
first time someone consumes me
you know what it is is you put the power
back to the person asking the question
and i think that's what draw
drew me to you because we are you know
this is why i do this podcast because
you know your thoughts your emotions
your beliefs your expectations your
negativity your positivity
that defines your whole existence and i
and on a spiritual
practical level i'm a spiritual
practical guy you know my mom's a single
parent with five kids i knew about the
hustle i knew about all that type of
stuff
the only difference is the hustling on
the street and hustling in business is
the same thing it's just
you're communicating differently yeah
the emotion and the feeling is still the
same
but now i've dropped the notion of how
the [ __ ] am i going to get there
and i know it's going to come right and
and what's even more fun
and this is how it's always been for me
is
it's going to get it's going to come as
redefined
you know when people were listening just
now and i'm getting goosebumps through
this interview which is fine that means
i know we're hitting on something
success or what's going to come
legacy or having it is always the
byproduct but if you can really get to
the place of
to your point believing that truth
well then you get to become the person
who defines that truth
you know i you know i i often say like
my ambitions are to be one of the great
entrepreneurs of all time and i
i get met by a lot of my friends and
definitely by
the comments section of social media
with incredible amounts of resistance of
no
around well you know jeff bezos and elon
musk and oprah
they're going to make more money and i'm
like you've defined
the greatest entrepreneur based on money
i've defined for me the greatest
entrepreneur is the one
who a because i agree at some level if
you're going to say that
you know you can't say you're the
greatest singer of all time and not have
a grammy or a
hit like there is market dynamics that
you have to respect
and i respect that i think i will be
financially successful enough to get
into the debate when my career is over
comma i don't see anyone as passionate
of giving free game at scale on a daily
basis
and really meaning it in the macro in
the micro
and i believe that i don't know what
else to tell you like yeah i'm very busy
and
my time is extremely valuable when i do
this podcast again i do it
because i like you and i'm cheering for
you and
and i appreciate it i'm being very happy
yeah i'm being very frank i'm
not unaware that there's gonna be new
people listening that didn't listen the
first time or maybe
i say something a different way and
they've come into this not liking me but
they love you and they're like wait a
minute you know
i know that but i also know that
a fresh interview with me gives you
leverage to get the next get like
i'm aware of that
and so to me that defines me as a great
entrepreneur somebody who's trying to
put other people on
in all his activities whether that's
financially whether that's giving
something you know i'd rather give you
ten thousand dollars in cash for this
podcast
than be on it for these 45 minutes
because i can do more with that
money like so sometimes it's money
sometimes it's time
sometimes it's a public co-sign i'll
give you another thing
sometimes it's already happened with you
for example sometimes it's
saying something behind the scenes when
someone's debating to do this or not and
i and i'm just using you
we've interacted so little this happens
to me times a hundred thousand
a month yep and i think good intent
karma caring about others self-esteem
and self-confidence that you can get
yours without tearing anyone else down
gets you into a place where you want to
build everyone else up
you know what that see i i see beauty in
that you see
because the you know was buddha an
entrepreneur
yes i think so was jesus yes any
any spiritual leader who again as i said
fully believe that
who lead from the heart and you know and
then like you said you know the
accolades thing and all that type of
stuff that's that's
that's acceptance we don't need that you
know it's like
for example this podcast i do you know
an episode with with guests who
who inspire me and then i do an episode
with guests
who send me like really heartfelt
courageous messages
about their personal lives about you
know i had someone on last week
who wanted to move to la told his mom he
was moving to la
seven months ago uh his brother's odin
in the bathroom
like courageous like i couldn't say that
at his age to anyone if
even a bunch of those things happen to
me and i was like well
would you like to talk about it and he
was like oh my god i would love to and
we
spoke it down we broke down and you know
his mum made him feel guilty about him
moving even though he's trying to
support her and everything else
and i just had to say look until you can
actually physically help yourself
mentally
you can't really help anyone else not
you know it's the same thing for me like
i have
niggling negative like i did the 21 day
on day
six of this meditation of abundance
there's some people who don't have who
don't live in abundance they live
completely
shut off and their life is exactly that
and i try and tell them
step out of yourself and study your life
you're exactly where you're supposed to
be based on who you are
and accountability that's what and and
accountability
is the key to the unlock of happiness
that nobody wants to use
yes because they don't like the
short-term pain of accountability
without realizing the long-term
happiness that it brings yes
and i think that's what uh made me you
know listen to you and
it was giving that back to the person
and them questioning being like oh [ __ ]
yes and then seeing their reaction and
seeing this whole
shield that's right from their body
that's right what ends up happening with
me
because of what i do it's like a mirror
with pressure
and the reason a lot of people don't
respond well to me is it's
manifesting someone in them that they're
not happy to expose they don't want me
poking at their zit
yes yes and it's it's funny because i
know like i i can imagine that your mind
is always
busy it's always on to because that's
that's who you are your life
um i read a book talk which was about
speed
and you know we're all busy you know i
was reading my daughter a bedtime story
and she was like again again and i was
like
baby i really have to like i've got i've
got things to do i love you but you need
to go to sleep
and then i i started reading this book
books come to me like that it's not
really
me searching it's kind of they come to
me when i need them and i needed that
because the guy wrote the book because
it was the exact same situation
and he was like what am i actually doing
that's in a rush
right it's it's prioritization and
selfless selfish i think about that a
lot
you know and and you have to be okay you
know i also think you have to be careful
not to over
judge yourself it is okay to be looking
at your phone
around something you're doing in your
life at the expense of your
young child who just wants your
attention
now it's not okay to do that for a
sustained period of time
where you now have neglect on your child
but i watch parents go the reverse my
friend
where they like beat themselves up for a
40-second lapse
and i'm like what are you doing why are
you and i think it's back to finding
that balance because i think you're
right
you know you want to get something on
the podcast prep for a podcast
and you're like wait a minute i should
sit 16 more minutes with darling this is
something i'll always remember plus i'm
putting deposits in
in a relationship i'm gonna care much
more about than if i did a solid
interview with gary vee
i think that's absolutely right i also
try when we talk about things like this
to bring up the counter like i just did
which is like and sometimes it's okay to
be selfish
for your own ambitions and your own
process find your balance
make sure you're not consistently doing
one and or the other
yes absolutely that's why now i have i
have the nanny in four times a week
and during those the other three days i
completely dedicate to her
so are evenings oh because i understand
the power that i have so
and also now i know that raising my
daughter brings me abundance
in in a sense where i'm my own social
experiment so i've
i haven't i wouldn't say i've removed
myself from from from society
but i've removed the distractions the
activity
from my life so that everything now is
key and i know exactly where it's going
i think it's a super interesting thing
i've i've said a lot and i don't know if
you've heard this but
seems like you might have i talk a lot
about living in a cocoon
like if you if you go to the if you go
to search.garyvaynerchuk.com i have a
search engine
if you search cocoon you'll be stunned
how often i say that and that's what you
just said
i believe so much of my happiness has
been
living in a cocoon which is wild because
i also think
i'm an incredibly successful voice
of the current yeah you're a people
person i'm a people person so i
know what's going on i'm not affected by
what's going on
i know what's going on on clubhouse i
know what's going on in vr
i know who's popping in hip hop and in
sports and in
influencers i know what's going on in
geopolitics i'm like really awake
to so much but completely detached from
yes and that that that's beautiful i
[ __ ] love that
you see um it's the same thing like a
you know
when you focus on poverty it brings more
poverty
what we need to focus on is the solution
to poverty whether that's educational
schools or
or jobs or correct or anything there's
so many different things like covid i'm
not consumed by i know that it's going
on in the world
and everyone who's consumed by is
affected by it what's my solution to it
i can help people financially i can you
know educate them on getting their mind
right i can send them mindful
meditations i can have them
you know put their mind into thinking
about health or better health
instead of you know because for me you
know i know again i'm practically
spiritually but
illnesses and are physical
manifestations in the body which to tell
you to stop doing what you're doing
emotionally physically and
environmentally i believe in that
so so that's okay i believe in math and
and art
i believe in black and white and gray i
think the reason people struggle with a
lot of what we're talking about here
when we go into this realm
is because they choose sides yeah steve
jobs and i don't know all the details
do i believe that you can just sit there
and will it mentally
sometimes i genuinely like i don't know
what i'm sorry i'm on the record
sometimes i believe the brain can
do i believe that's always answer no i
do not i think sometimes
math is a good answer you got to figure
out when and how and what but
once we become a culture of and versus
or this is a very big point of mine
in general something i'm going to be
talking about more because
i just unveiled it a little bit here
with a little more oomph i say it a lot
but i'm starting to really get him like
wait
a minute the reason so much works for me
is i live in
and and all these people want it to be
or
they're so obsessed with it to be one or
the other
when it is always and
you know even if you think about our
religious divides our
racial divides our social divides our
country
you know america has a racist you uh
europe has an anti-semitic issue like
you know right like yep it's because of
ore
yes why can't it be and
i think i think that my my perspective
of how i live is i don't know [ __ ] about
anything
and there's beauty in that the old me
used to fear the unknown
now i [ __ ] love it i'm welcoming it
with open arm bring it because i don't
know anything
this is great and i think it puts you on
a level plateau of being i
one of the things that i do worry about
like uh
being transparent is i get mad when
people think i'm egotistical because i'm
so conviction oriented yeah
because really if you ask me what
speak about traits that i got you here i
would argue humility is at the top
humility and patience yet
i seem frantic and borderline
egotistical on almost every video clip
because i'm passionate conviction and
i'm fast
so my human manifestation of
communication style is one thing
my actions as a human are completely the
opposite
see i i don't see that because but then
again i really yeah you know
and outside you know i i you don't lead
with ego
otherwise you would attract egotistical
situations to you and that's just not
who you are you're uncomfortably
thoughtful on this issue my friend
i mean i think i think you could have no
no without you know without you being
humble or like me
flattering like i think you're pretty
aware
that you come at it a little bit
different than the masses
yeah yeah luckily luckily i think i'm
also
interesting enough that makes people
look a second or third time
and most people are intuitive enough
that if they get enough context they're
like wait a minute
you know nothing's i mean i and i also
probably in a weird way
manifest a little bit of the
underestimation i do think i'm extremely
attracted to the underdog
situation because of all my
circumstances
and i sometimes wonder if i a little bit
like for example you may know this
since you consume you you've got a lot
of context
my team is so frustrated that i don't
talk about being smart
the number one conversation with my
inner circle in my content is
you don't tell people you're smart
and i rebuttal with how is that going to
bring anyone value
yeah yeah and they have gotten smarter
in the rebuttal which is like
hey that validation might help you
affect more people and then you start
having the game of
who do you get who you don't get like
and you go through that whole thing but
you know i get it and i think you're
right
but i also know that most people can't
see that yeah
yeah and i i don't think you need to say
i mean
you know i never went to school i know
you didn't so my i never believed
i was smart because i didn't have the
accreditation up until a certain point
and i was like actually
same
wait a minute why did why was i
successful with financial and happiness
a lot more than almost the rest of my
high school combined class
you know like you start getting more
thoughtful and wisdom-oriented
you start realizing the framework of
life is different and you start building
on that
yeah so in terms of like you know during
this whole time period you know since i
mean
to be honest like during this transition
from march till
now it's been you know i don't know
what's going on in the world i i don't
consume myself with it i just know
i can help the people around me and and
then we rise together
um how have you adapted as a person
mentally business-wise
or should i say transitioned during this
period i mean
because you're pretty online anyway so i
feel like you know you would
could have just taken a step forward or
whatever how have you transitioned as
a person as a human during this time
um i've taken an advantage
it's a great word yeah i've taken
advantage i uh
i've been the kind of person that always
loves
christmas break because everyone else is
off too
me too me too that's the only time when
no one's trying to go
yeah yeah so knowing that everyone else
was in covet 2
was very good for me and i said you know
i'm going to spend more time you know
with my family
see my parents so much more i'm going to
rekindle friendships so like great
friends that you just get out of
patterns of communication with
so i really focused on kevin rose
founder of dig.com you know some
that for example right ashton you know
like some friends
my college friends the 301 the spot crew
big shout out to mount ida college
you know so i rekindled um i
got deeper into my kids so that's been
huge
um i've gotten very i've gained
and i've learned how muscle mass has
gained i've probably gained
seven to ten pounds of muscle
um i've gotten more sleep
i have business developed at a level
i've never had before
using linkedin because now i have a
laptop and i've you know i'm doing
multiple things at once
because i didn't have a laptop for five
years at all on my phone so double
screens has made me more efficient
but most of all let me tell you a very
thoughtful thing that i think you'll
enjoy because i know you now
i've taken an advantage by
even becoming more confident and
conviction oriented around my beliefs
i believed because i went through it
with 9 11
and the economic crisis but it had been
a long time and the companies
and things i was doing were so much
smaller than what i'm doing now
it was in my belief that i was a wartime
general
that when [ __ ] gets bad i get better
this was a real challenge vayner x my
holding company in vaynermedia
and i have a lot of companies underneath
it
fell in the middle so we got no
government support
we weren't small enough we weren't big
enough
we were in growth mode so we didn't have
a lot of profit the last three years so
we weren't sitting on
cash we had multiple major clients say
they're not going to pay us on time
immediately the day covet hit
i have to let go of 80 people which is
all 80 of them sit in my stomach and my
heart right now
let alone a year ago we had to innovate
product and services
we did all of those wildly well
including expanding
starting companies including
investments that i made doing extremely
well
including me being wildly right about
proper football and basketball and
sports cards as an investment
alternative alt
so i sit here a year later happier
more fulfilled and more successful
the end beautiful beautiful growth
that's evolution i think that there are
people who do well
in trying circumstances i just believe
it i believe that's why there is a term
called wartime and peacetime generals
you know i think that's why some people
are have a plan until they get punched
in the face like mike tyson said
yeah like i think i'm extremely good at
getting punched by
in the face because i think i was
punched in the face for the first six
seven years of my life moving a lot
language barriers
fear of immigration not speaking the
language getting picked on a lot
losing losing losing losing it became a
comfort
yeah as you know for me is um all my
experiences
all the good the bad the ugly all that
type of everything that happened to me
i i i've welcomed it i've loved it
because
i wouldn't be where i'm at right now and
you know what i i genuinely like where
i'm at right now
you know i'm starting to love it like
i'm generally starting to open up myself
and being like oh [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] good and you know you
don't realize
your childhood when you're in it until
you actually have kids
and then you're like and i see my
daughter's life i'm like yo there was
some bad [ __ ] that happened
but that's okay because i'm good and i
don't i don't dwell on that and it's in
it
this points back to my next thing of of
dreams um
i'd love to know because you know i have
a there's one defining moment during
you know i was working at sony atv i
lost my job it was a great job
um and and i had i wouldn't say
self-doubt i knew i didn't get along
with the ceo i knew that things weren't
happening and i knew
spiritually that something was coming
and i couldn't change that thought
process
um and then one night you know when i
got let go all that type of stuff but
you know me i'm
i adapt so i have more than one revenue
of income so i know when one goes down
the other will pick up the pace if i
focus on it and i had this one dream and
i don't like
open doors in my house i don't know it
must be a respect thing you know the
doors should be closed
and the utility room in my dream was
open and it was
it was dark so i opened the door and
something grabbed my arm
and i couldn't pull it back and in the
dream i couldn't scream i can do
anything and i woke up and i was like oh
you need to let go you need to let go of
that whole situation
you did it you spent six years it was
amazing you signed some of the most
biggest artists you had some of the
biggest hits
and you need to let go and the minute i
let i did that
just things that i weren't even focused
on even though i was focused on
abundance
came in and now i'm in in a process of
like buying catalogs of those
songwriters
were amazing for equity companies and
catalogs that i never even would even
think or dream about are coming in and
and i feel like it's minimal effort for
me now because i'm
i'm being i'm floating on the river and
i'm going with with the flow
yeah that's kind of where i'm at and i'd
love to know about if there's a defining
dream or any dreams that you have or
any because for me they're symbols that
they break down your whole day your
whole
life up to that point and i'd love to
dive a little bit on that with you
it's a great great question
dreams right dreams see i've got gary
thinking
yeah no no you need more of that it's
great i appreciate it i love
i love thinking and thoughtfulness and
pondering
um the dreams that get a hold of me
are a little different first of all i
think
i am as grateful as one can be when it
comes around profession
when i tell you my profession brings me
zero anxiety ever
ever that is actually the truth i
just don't think money and work and
business
means anything even though i am probably
one of the most
recognized internet entrepreneurs on the
planet
but that that's why it makes you that no
[ __ ] yeah
comma to answer your question
i dream a lot as a kid i dreamt a lot
about a family reunion
in russia and every time the plane would
crash in siberia
and every time it would be a different
mix of my 12 relatives who survived with
me
and then we would try to survive and
then i would always wake up this was a
very aggressive recurring dream wow
i dream a lot about
um the health and well-being of my
i think i fear only one thing
the the health and well-being of the
people i love
and so i think when i think about dreams
i don't remember most dreams like most
people
but the ones that as you were talking
and i was pondering
and i kind of paused and said dreams i
realized huh
pretty much the [ __ ] i remember is
around extremely negative situations
that when i wake up i'm so [ __ ]
grateful it's not true
that no matter what the day has in store
me in front as long as it's not that
i think i got very [ __ ] lucky i think
i grew up in a culture
where my parents and grandparents
generation
died so young in soviet russia people
were dying in their 40s and 50s
alcoholism depression i mean it's the
soviet union i mean
one of the worst regimes in the history
of time
for humans suppression at scale yeah
um that i think i'm you know
i'm so affected by it that it's
in my blood in my subconscious
and it's it's it's very hard for me
to worry about anything but
like they say in russia to good health
that's all i ever heard
it's all i ever knew to good health to
good health to good health
i never heard anybody cheers to
prosperity in my entire life
lou i i was you know i to this day
and my friends know this when we do
cheers i you know sometimes it'll be
like a big deal
you know i've had some big exits in my
career had some big moments
you know and some of my american friends
are just not even american like
friends like to to rezzy our big company
exit or to
gary being on conan o'brien or to
whatever right
never i'm always like no no to good
health
boom boom i think it's my religion and i
think
it plays out in a lot of places and i
think uh when it comes to dreams
i just realized it plays out there too
wow and
that kind of brings me on my next point
is you know i don't know if you've ever
dove into the multiverse or any of that
type of things of
say you know what would gary be doing
now
if he wasn't doing what he's doing now
and if you've put enough energy like for
example you said the dream of of the
plane and you you
there's probably i know i'm going a bit
far-fetched but
and i but i believe this there's
probably another you who is living that
existence
tapping into that existence you know so
for example you
and this is why it's so important to me
for example i wanted to play soccer like
i played semi-pro in the uk and then i
got injured i kept getting injured i
kept getting injured and i can trace it
back to my negativity of when i used to
start the game is like
don't get injured instead of just being
in the game and enjoying the game and
i would always get injured what would
garyvee be doing now if he wasn't
doing what he's doing i have two very
good answers on this because i
it this question comes very natural to
me
one i would be a guidance counselor
in a school wow i get incredible
pleasure
hence back to something we touched on
earlier of
providing guidance through words
to young people i love it
it being a guidance counselor in a high
school would fulfill me tremendously
yep yep number two
i would be by the way i'd be the
guidance counselor and definitely a head
coach of one of the teams that i would
be
ravaged and savage you know on the pitch
or
on the basketball court um number two
i would be a scientist
who went to some remote place like the
mountains in peru
studying a very specific narrow species
for 26 years in the wild only to come
back out
and write a book or make a documentary
of the pink tailed goats
i the the only other thing i can think
of
that i enjoy more than
pontificating debate to change
perspective
to lead to more good in the world is the
work
required to watch to be able to give the
advice
see i believe that i've been in what's
that i said the heart
that's you gary i think i've been
observing
my whole life yeah i think people hear
me cut off people on a podcast or talk a
lot
and they don't realize that 93 of my
life is listening
you don't see me every minute you just
see you know i'm very good at creating
content and distributing it on the
internet so you think i'm always talking
but what i'm actually doing is listening
all the time so that my talking has
value
yeah yeah and i think that i think
that's the your background that's your
upbringing that's that's the struggles
that's all that type of stuff because
i'm the same i'm always i'm watching i'm
listening i'm learning
constantly i'm never not learning you
know i used to think um
you know when i was younger and i was
you know we'd have these like mentors
um and actually he was actually pretty
good to be honest
and it was like a bearings bank which
was one of the biggest banks in the uk
um and it was like underprivileged kids
so you had a bunch of us
poor kids just running around at this
bank and he would sit there and he
explained to you the fundamentals of
banking and money and saving and all
that type of stuff
and i was like holy [ __ ] i said i i want
to learn how to
throw me in a room of these people and i
want to learn how to make money
so i would study how they spoke and what
how they you know how they resonated
what they wore
you know i go into meetings and i'd you
know dress decently and
and then you know someone here he was
one actually told me that the two things
you need in life
when you're taking a meeting is a nice
watch in a bag
so i would get a nice watch at the time
which was like a 500 buck watch but
to me that was a lot of money and it was
like i got this beautiful
black briefcase and every time i would
go and they were like oh nice watching
bag and i was like
yeah i'm going to make some money it's
funny it's funny back to sandbagging
myself
i was thinking when you were just
talking this is something i've got to
figure out
because it's fascinating i i actually
actually i'm going to self-diagnose and
i have some insight to this
i actually think that i like the process
so much that i actually don't want the
riches
that are associated with my natural
talent that
the reason i never wore a suit or got a
watch
or a handbag the reason i cursed on
stage every day of my life when i
started my career when everyone told me
i could be one of the great speakers of
all time
but i had to drop the cursing was
i wasn't willing to compromise what
naturally felt happy
and intuitively felt right to me for
what others perceived
would be short-term success yep
yep or i've literally sabotaged myself
to slow down the acceleration of my
destiny because i enjoy the taste of the
process
so much yeah but you know it's it's this
warped view on what's
right or wrong there there isn't one you
know there isn't one like there isn't
one
the reason why you know i actually just
read a book on that yesterday
um i'm reading a ton of this this author
called osho
who's amazing but he was he was like the
one of the most controversial people
since jesus and he like
breaks everything down from everything
pretty much in terms of accolades it's
like um
he had this one guy who was an indian
author who wrote beautiful poetry
and got no recognition in india it was
terrible like you know all that type of
stuff and then transformed it into
english
and then won the nobel prize or was
offered the nobel prize
and he was like i don't [ __ ] want it
i didn't write it for this i wrote it
because i love doing what i'm doing
and same as you you love doing what
you're doing so naturally
the success the the the financials that
everything else comes with
with the loving doing what you're doing
that gentleman's a little bit
more whether it's pure or to one side
um i especially while my parents are
alive
i'll take them all yeah i'll take every
prize yes
you know i don't i don't take the prizes
that are fake i get offered all the time
to be
a man of this and winner of that and and
i know that they're just schemes to get
me to buy a table
and they're not true and they're not
based on merit yeah
but but yeah i get it i just
listen i don't mind a trophy if i've
earned it
i love it that's why i don't like the
middle right i don't like the judges
i'm not there for the olympics where the
german or russian judge can [ __ ] me up
because that's subjectivity and that's
politics yep i'm here for merit
right i can deal with the booing and the
hissing in social media
because i know how the movie's going to
end yeah yeah
beautiful you i'd say harry i tell you
what you are the [ __ ]
um i just want i just want two points
for me because it's
something that i've kind of stumbled and
not stumbled across
i was always raised you know my mum was
always like don't buy anything unless
you got physical cash for it
so i was always you know credit for me
wasn't really a thing or credit history
or any other type of [ __ ] and i had to
build that up for now
now i'm starting to realize that my
money can be making money for me
instead of remaining stagnant so you
know obviously i've started investing in
you know bitcoin all this type of stuff
preaching
it's so funny how much similarities you
and i have i'm very similar
how old are you i am 35. this is amazing
do you know that i was 30
i was i was 34 years old when i came to
that realization
yeah yeah but you know it's it's i was
pretty much homeless everything else
from 20 26. yeah
let's stop right there actually i'm
sorry interrupt but i want to make a
huge point for the audience because it's
going to be a nice bow
it's because it was our perspective yeah
that's all
yeah forget about anything else yeah
it's literally or mommy dad you're just
mom
poorly forget about all that because
there's plenty of people poor who
believe in the stock market there's
plenty of people rich who believe and
say like
it was just our perspective yeah then we
learned
and then we readjusted and guess what i
do both i still sit
trust me i'm still an immigrant at heart
i still have a little cash
pile that i'll never touch no matter
what because if the whole world burns i
need to make that and to your point
i have crypto and i have cash and i have
assets i even have some tulips
in a safe just in case those things come
back so like you know i'm with you on
that
100 it's funny because the the
the harder i work mentally the less i
make it financially and i'm not talking
you know you don't you work hard
but you meant your mental state is at a
point where you
you know you know when i was working
hard i didn't know [ __ ]
i didn't know i was the the working hard
was the struggle
you see what i'm saying so nothing would
come in now i'm open
and i work smart to me it doesn't feel
like work anymore it's it's love
um and and my question for you would be
just help away obviously
oh boy does that god if we could get
self-awareness and self-love on a
pedestal and culture we'd be in a much
better place
that i mean that's for me that's what it
is you know i don't see me it is too
i don't see you know negativity i don't
see positivity if it comes in
i can flick it away it just is it just
is you know everyone said i'm with you
but that because it's a lack of humility
yeah and it's also
a rise of entitlement yeah there'd be no
confusion my friend
entitlement entitlement is poison yes
yeah but you see you know the whole
thing you know this whole argument of
privilege versus no privilege but a
privileged person doesn't know their
privilege
that's why it's privilege a person who
isn't privileged
wants to be privileged but doesn't
understand that you know it's like you
know
because i read all these comments and i
have a ton of you know not celebrity
friends but
people who i sign who are talented
people like musicians and stuff and you
see their comments
you know you've always had for example
billy eilish you know her parents
are actors and actresses oh she's never
struggled but she has her own struggles
she doesn't get ready for this on the
record
yeah i think it's much more challenging
being my son than being me
yeah 100 same for my daughter i would
never want
that path because no matter what
he accomplishes because i can already
see he's got entrepreneurial stuff
nobody so he has to get insular
if he's unable to get insular he'll
always have that as a very big
thing that hangs over his head yes yes
the end
oh i don't i i think it is so
uncomfortably inappropriate to make
assumptions
of someone else's struggles yes you
could see a very rich white male in
america and they're like he's privileged
and i'm like
or he's deeply insecure from bad
parenting
and he's mentally completely
unprivileged
i think the greatest privilege in the
world is peace of mind or on mind how
you put it yeah
no mind no no mind so to me
one day they'll be able to show that you
you can call one day you can
dig me up for my grave test me for it
see that i was off the charts and then
you could say i was privileged because
you'll be right
because this operating system in my dome
has given me everything
yeah it's you're pointing to the wrong
spot you're supposed to point oh sorry
it made a little chest heart
i just i'm just very grateful to be on
this show
to have the people i care about to be
alive for all of it i've got to run but
i appreciate you thank you
thank you man gary seriously youtube
watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you